ah
ouais assez merveilleux
ah ouais
oui et à leur nouvelle calédonie et
c'est là où je vais
depuis ma sélection au concours chacun
son rêve j'attendais avec impatience de
connaître ma destination
cap vers le bout du monde deux jours
d'avion deux jours à réviser tous les
films consacrés aux animaux et oui je
suis une mordue de nature sauvage te
fais
craquer
au
réveil c'est les yeux grands ouverts que
j'entre dans mon rêve la nouvelle
calédonie est entouré par le plus grand
lagon au monde c'est ici que je vais
installer ma salle de consultation pour
quelques jours hors du commun
je suis vétérinaire mon rêve m'installer
aux antipodes alors pourquoi pas la
nouvelle calédonie pour m'aider à
choisir j'aurais le meilleur des guides
[Musique]
merci
on est au pied du lagon et là tu sais où
on va aller non c'est la surprise david
lantin mystérieux la procurer des
bouteilles de plongée oui à priori vers
m'a dit de mettre un maillot de balle
est donc
beau gosse non philippe freu là est un
plongeur réputé en nouvelle calédonie un
passionné du lagon son camp de base se
situe au beau milieu du récif corallien
le fameux ponton voilà le pompier venu à
bord merci philippe plonge régulièrement
pour surveiller la biodiversité
sous-marine ce sera ma première mission
souley tu vas noter par exemple que ce
soit propre aura ou corail ouais pour
iphone lierse et quand ça fait des
plateaux tu sais ouais c'est là que je
vois que j'adore plongée mais en fait
j'y connais rien
[Rires]
et pour le suivi du parc du grand nouméa
donc c'est des stations d'observation
qui permettent de voir comment ça évolue
certaines zones du lagon dans le temps
d'accord donc on compare ça avec des
données dia 80 exactement
j'avoue que ça me fait un petit peu peur
le moment tant attendu
retourner dans mon élément l'océan j'ai
commencé à plonger à ça a été une vraie
révélation ce que j'aime c'est le
silence parce que ben dans mon métier
comme suis tout le temps en train de
parler aux gens d'expliquer
d'écouter ce qu'ils me disent donc je
trouve dans le dans la parole et du coup
d'être en plongée
c'est reposant et touchant de bonnes
auspices des tables un peu de méditation
où j'arrive à vivre ça à rien
[Musique]
première plongée dans le pacifique
nous identifions chaque bête et chaque
branche de corail sur des zones
délimitées
[Musique]
le lagon concentre plus de 1600 espèces
de poissons et 352 courau
pas étonnant qu'il soit classé au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
[Musique]
en fait
c'est super bien équilibrée d'angoissé
traîne à magie des bons profs
ça se voit et puis après tu as a way
après il ya aussi des prédispositions ta
pratique
j'ai juste oublié de préciser un petit
détail je ne mange jamais de poisson ces
défis les plus sombres pourquoi
l'at on pas le choix ah les poissons je
les aime bien vivants dans l'eau a
alors commencé voilà
oui un petit bout aussi
j'ai pris un gros bout laruns attention
ouais
je préfère le poulet c'est le poulet
barquette
après avoir plongé dans ses fonds sous
maman il temps d'explorer le lagon vue
du ciel
je me perds aussi du brouillard en bois
savall bien moi une grande première
c'est avec ce drôle d'engin que je pars
explorer mon nouveau terrain de jeu
e
[Musique]
et
des eaux turquoise à perte de vue
une barrière de corail presque aussi
grande que la grande barrière
australienne
le lagon calédonien me prend aux tripes
et j'ai encore beaucoup de passion à
nageoires ou à écailles à découvrir
[Musique]
je
vous ne pouvez pas nous louper chic de
blanc place in translation dans le métro
de tokyo moi c'est arielle à côté de moi
mon mari peter un truc de dingue ce
concours chacun son lave on a juste
envoyé une lettre de motivation + réussi
le casting et nous voici propulsés dans
notre rêve au japon une grande première
pour nous
je réalise pas encore
c'est réel en fait
satan doute pas vu un truc et la vanne
corner
[Musique]
1la content tu regardes
premier bain de foule sur la planète
japon ici à shibuya le carrefour
emblématique de tokyo
chaque jour deux cent mille habitants se
croisent rien qu à cette intersection à
chaque coin de rue et looks improbables
des grands malades un décor futuriste
c'est assez déplaisant c'est franchement
impressionnant
franchement attention la musique
c'est incroyable je sais pas combien de
passage piéton c'est dingue à temps vous
connaissez la dernière tendance made in
japon
occupez vous de ma femme el abdallah
kallal
[Musique]
savoir que réglera nos comptes tout à
l'heure
je vais te défoncer la gueule j'espère
la pomme est grave je te déteste
j'aime pas que les gens ne touche plus
tard
moi mon truc c'est les mangas les fans
de bandes dessinées japonaises donnent
rendez vous ici dans le quartier de
akihabara au cutter en prince charmant
de boeuf c'est un godzilla que je le
préfère
[Musique]
genève continue à aller à calais
on va donner l'impression du manga c'est
le club dorothée et à toute une
génération qui s'est mise à aimer les
mangas
à tout ça à cause de dorothée way
le japon peut dire merci à dorothée
goldorak candy bioman tout ce beau monde
m'a donné une envie monter un salon de
thé japonais à paris avec des mangas en
libre accès le manga je maîtrise mais
pour le thé tout reste à faire nous
avons rendez vous avec un des maîtres du
thé au japon pour
chanter c'était vraiment et oui surprise
il est français merci de nous recevoir
au problème ça nous fait plaisir
c'est très joli et ça sent très très
très très beau
c'était pas quand on est une star ici il
est un des premiers à avoir parfumer le
thé vert la sacro-sainte boissons au
japon
installé depuis vingt ans à tokyo
stéphane est devenu le nouvel empereur
de l'or vert c'est du thé vert bonjour
parfume avec des arômes
c'est bon
on mettrait presque sa bouche dedans
quand tu lis ans plus tard
j'essaie d'avoir qu'une gamme de doter
qui sont japonaises le natsumi quand
c'est un thé
qui est à la mandarine
c'est divin à ça sans trop
vous semblent être intéressés et vous
c'est quoi votre vous avez un projet
particulier salt et pas uniquement sur
le terrain fait ce que je voudrais ce
serait ouvrir un café librairie
japonisant à paris un peu comme ce que
vous proposez en fait des produits de ce
type là d'été comme les vôtres et
éventuellement des pâtisseries
d'inspiration japonaise je vous en
servir opté froid
des fraudeurs là je vous fais rente et
la joie d'être hantée la prude
ancien sommelier stéphane apporte aussi
sa french touch il fait déguster son thé
comme du vin le thé vert quand vous
faites une fusion à froid ils
ressemblent vraiment au vin blanc on
prend le vert si on a pris le verre
le point suivant c'est de l'amener au
niveau du nombre les arômes et si le
visuel a été bon les arômes sont bons on
a envie de le mettre la bouche oui donc
c'est ce que j'ai recréé avec le thé
donc ça sert comme ça dans les
restaurants ça sert comme ça kampaï
peter aller
et ça c'est monté c'est monté un prune
c'est celui-là voilà ils sont forts ils
sont forts mais quand on le fait à l'eau
il vient plus neutre
c'est déstabilisant pas que par rapport
à ce que j'ai l'habitude de boire tu
vois
nous sortons un livret des bons conseils
de stéphane
prochain rendez vous avec lui au pied du
mont fuji au milieu des champs de thé
[Musique]
je m'appelle mélanie j'ai 16 ans dans
quelques minutes j'embarque pour
montréal au québec
c'est la plus jeune des candidats
d'aujourd'hui et c'est mélanie et je
sais que la vie a basculé le jour du
casting de chacun son rêve et surtout
j'espère vraiment que ça serait un rêve
qui pourra peut-être même de changer un
petit peu ton destin
pour la première fois je vais prendre
l'avion je ne suis jamais allé à
l'étranger
mon conte de fées c'est d'abord un
groupe de clowns je suis élève à l'école
du cirque de châtellerault mon but
intégrer une grande compagnie et c'est
en amérique que je pars réaliser mon
rêve
[Musique]
lui c'est hugo il ne me connaît pas mais
moi je les ai vu des dizaines de fois
sur youtube se produire sous un
chapiteau
moi c'est hugo
la santé était prête pour l'aventuré
ouais ça va paraître
on y va ces bars et
me voici face à mes premier gratte-ciel
voilà montréal bienvenue mais
bienvenue
donc là du coup voici montréal et là bas
c'est parti pour une semaine d'aventuré
peut être moins folle
je suis super impatient tu es jeune tu
es prête
[Musique]
non c'est pas non
[Rires]
allez c'est pas montréal ces champs mais
mais c'est lui que je kiffe le plus
c'est hugo un modèle pour moi on a fait
la même école et aujourd'hui il est un
des jeunes talents du cirque au québec
quand ça fait combien de temps au père
noël
j'entame ma sixième année donc après
châtellerault
à 20 ans je suis parti à montréal pour
étudier à l'école nationale de cirque
qui durent donc trois ans
la suivante à ma troisième année de
tournée du coup là je suis en train de
faire du papier pour être résident
permanent
le québec est devenue l'eldorado du
cirque contemporain un cirque sans
animaux dans lequel le clown est à la
fois danseurs et comédiens parmi les
pionniers le cirque du soleil et des
compagnies comme les 7 doigts de la main
c'est cette troupe qu'a rejoint hugo
[Musique]
après
ils sont en train de faire une nouvelle
création sur le spectacle cuisine et
confessions salut les amis je vous
présente mélanie
- la fin de la semaine je vais faire un
festival qui s'appelle claire magnin
avec patrick léonard un des fondateurs
aussi des 7 doigts on va faire la mise
en scène du spectacle du coup on va voir
qu'est ce que l'on peut faire avec toi
tu reviens dans ce spectacle
ça marche ok on va aller s'entraîner
le défi est énorme je ne suis jamais
monté sur scène j'ai cinq jours pour
être à la hauteur comme moi hugo n'est
pas un enfant de la balle nous ne sommes
pas mais avec un nez rouge notre seul
moyen de nous imposer c'est de dompter
notre corps comment j'arrive et vouloir
faire du sud j'ai été aux portes
ouvertes d'une petite école de cirque à
montluçon
du coup ça je suis super bien amusé pas
je me suis inscrit dans une association
à chicago c'est venu comme ça c'est
devenu une passion
une des bases pour assurer au cirque
c'est les équilibres moi c'est pas mon
fort
mais ce qu'on sait c'est yahoo
j'aime bien un design
les idées
[Musique]
ok
comment tu toi
c'est montrer des trucs en équipe ça
parce que tu pourrais montrer un truc
entre que tu sais pas faire
essayer
cette fois ci je peux t'aider
et oui je suis content or sioniste
auquel régime bush quoi
ai-je pas possible on est toujours à
côté mieux
assurer les biens
[Rires]
ok j'ai autre chose à gagner
chacun ça se fait
tout petit tuner tnt à la tête je
m'amuse et je trouvais ça drôle montant
sous les côtes j'ai toujours fait sauf
que je me rendais pas vraiment compte
que j'avais beaucoup de souplesse et un
jour je me suis dit bah tiens j'ai envie
de faire des choses en souplesse et
finalement je me suis rendu compte que
je peux faire vachement autre chose
et je pense faudrait que tu gars est ce
dont l'a en fait utilise ton des atouts
corporels
pour faire une discipline tout ce que je
veux dire
à côté des artistes des 7 doigts de la
main je sens que je n'ai vraiment pas le
niveau j'ai encore des années de travail
et d'entraînement
[Musique]
mais ça leur sein
bah ça m'intéresserait vraiment vraiment
content du tout dans tout ça c'est que
vraiment compagnies comme ça
un boulot voulons dire
c'est du boulot agréable le matin je me
lève
ouais c'est ça exactement ça vaut le
coup
le clash pas tellement lâche pas
[Musique]
là je me sens comme un poisson dans
l'eau
aujourd'hui je pose ma trousse de veto
dans l'aquarium de nouméa
l'aquarium regroupe les espèces les plus
emblématiques du lagon et parmi elles
mon chouchou le requin point de grease
pointe blanche citrons ils sont présents
sur toute la côte est aujourd'hui
ça va être leur fait
à toile où
il a bougé
ça va contre toute ma nature ça de
rassurez vous c'est juste pour nourrir
les prédateurs avides et les musées
non
je veux pas je vais pas me reconvertir
en plus
on prépare les poissons à bien résister
au stress en soi une alimentation enfin
en et bichonnent
on va bien d'être poissons d'aquarium
oui gîte et couvert assuré
parmi les pensionnaires les nautiles
ces fossiles sont encore plus ancien que
les dinosaures
[Musique]
au fil de ma tournée des popotes je
mesure la richesse des espèces qui
peuplent le lagon calédonien
[Musique]
nathalie langoustes
non voilà
et voici le grand moment le repas des
requins tu vas commencer par me
distribuer tsahal a en fait
dit vas-y vas-y voilà
on va essayer de donner à manger aux
gros requins gris
aller j'ai peut-être un client il ya des
chances
voilà
très bien
allez vas-y tu mets dans l'eau
voilà on va pas trop le charger la sa
ration est déjà largement bonne vous
baisser mon destin je sais pas si je
suis prête à bosser quand même dans un
aquarium parce que j'avoue que des
coupes et du poisson et mettre les mains
dedans ça me je prends sur moi là on
dirait pas mais je prends sur moi
après faire du soin s'il ya des
blessures
on va faire deux ans vétérinaire c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait me plaire ça
peut être sympa
cap vers le lagon
juste en face de la baie de nouméa il y
à un nid l'objet de bien des fantasmes
c'est sur ce minuscule bout de recife
que squat plus de 4000 serpent marins
parmi les plus venimeux au monde
chaque année clergue aux harengs et
volontaires pour leur rendre visite
spécialiste des serpents marin à
l'université de nouméa claire vibre plus
d'excitation que de peur et ça c'est pas
sa main une trace de certains non non
non je ne sais pas ce que c'est ça mais
si c'est une trace de ces reports bien
sûr de soi c'est une trace
j'ai passé une paire de garde parce que
c'est toujours mieux de mettre des gants
quand on manipule et dessert pour venir
et je vois pas mal de traces même s'il
ya pas mal de traces on va peut-être
aller voir par là
or voilà regarde là tu me vois dans les
faits et voici la bête est chez moi je
les prendre dans la bri les données
piqué
on les appelle les tricots rayés le
garde horizontale ça tu as l'habitude
donc les petits certains shows alors ça
c'est un garçon si tu regardes la tête
et la queue le motif est quasiment le
même parce qu'en fait car le serpent est
en train de chercher sa nourriture dans
le récif il a la tête dans le trou et
l'accueil qui dépasse et donc un
prédateur qui passe il se dit oh je
l'attrapé à certains aliments l'accueil
et c'est beaucoup moins graves notamment
la tête donc c'est alors pour les
prédateurs cette coque imite la tête
c'est la vraie info qu' un serpent
venimeux en plus donc
ils sont très intéressants ils ont plein
d'adaptation qui sont intéressantes à
étudier et
c'est un peu un des symboles de la
calédonie
voilà il va rentrer chez lui
tranquillement
avec leur petite bouille de premier de
la classe difficile d'imaginer que les
tricots rayés on en venait dix fois plus
puissant que le cobra royal
un serpent qui est assez sympathique qui
est très jolie puis ok faut qu'ils
voudraient c'est sympa on peut le
manipuler
il se laisse faire
moi j'aime bien c'est fort sympathique
petit serpent
et regarde
voilà justin y en avait un qui nous
attendait
donc le serpent tricot rayé bleu donc ça
c'est un petit individu l'invention
n'est pas douloureuse du tout il ya
juste de petits pois rouges et les
premiers symptômes c'est la fatigue et
les yeux qui se ferment tout seul mais
mais on a quand même largement le temps
d'aller à l'hôpital ou des médecins
quand il a tapé sens n'est pas pris en
charge est ce que ça peut être mortel
alors en calédonie il ya eu deux cas
recensés parce que justement les
médecins urgentistes de l'hôpital ont
fait les études dessus parce que ça les
intéresse et eu deux cas recensés de
morsures mortelles par des serpents
marins en plus d'un siècle donc c'est
quand même pas si fréquent que ça
d'accord c'est là qu'on voit la veto
ça arrive oui malheureusement c'est pas
quand ils ont un bon d'ailleurs toile n
blessures et souvent quand ils ont un
bobo il ya des tic qui se met dessus
et regarde la note la source cas nous on
sait pas combien de 3,4
donc c'est pour ça tu vois c'est quand
même mieux de mettre des gants parce
qu'on envoie la marque et on s'est passé
trois ans à traves alors là on en trouve
déjà 2 up et encore
waouh c'était un bonne nuit ça
donc ça nous fait quand même tu vois ce
caillou il y en avait quand même il ya
encore un set
j'ai grandi ici donc j'ai été habitué
très jeunes à partager la plage avec les
tricots rayés donc ici ici les gens en
partant des tricots rayés en général y
sont habitués même de temps en temps il
joue un peu trop avec ce qui est pas
très prudent
nini peau les serpents ni pour les gens
ah les mémères
haut quand même un hall à
la tête des gens de plus joli et le bleu
c'est chic
[Musique]
silence ça pousse
bienvenue dans les plantations de thé au
sud de tokyo c'est ici que stéphane
antonio se fournir en dormeur pour nous
aider à monter notre salon japonais
notre nouveau coach tenait à nous
ramener à l'origine la feuille et c'est
de la bonne voie la st peter
ça sent bon c'est un frère
sont bons ça
ça sent très bon
ça secoue rivières c'est très net sur
cette journée très joli vase il essaie
de vue du procès pasqua voilà ça c'est
la façon japonais c'est pour ça que tu
as des chances sont super jolie quoi oui
régulier voilà alors que t'as pas ça
alors que tu as à pau tapas années en
iran ni on admire ni assez lent ni en
chine parce qu'ils ont d'autres façons
de faire le test d'accord
[Musique]
derrière ce sas la feuille deviens tu es
super bon
elles sont passées à vapeur ça comme ça
reichshoffen il est celle de la machine
la leaf feuille là il commence à
dérouler et roulis les rooney les roues
ligne heureux comme ça une fois que vous
livrons tomber ils sont tombés ils
émettent là dedans
et il s est vu salma
la première fois
stéphane qui est ici chez lui un peu
comme dans sombre gelé natale mais ici
sur des coteaux de tétouan impression
devant des vignobles
et en fonction de son tout c'est pareil
c'est rude que ce ne sont des feuilles
mais en fond sur la façon du travail
tenté est tenté la différence est comme
le vin c'est du raisin en fonction de
vos la chanson tu prépares ton truc ça
va devenir cette fois du banc rouge
choix du vin blanc ça ne va on se
désole
[Musique]
nous poursuivons notre route vers kyoto
l'ancienne capitale impériale du japon
connue aussi pour être la capitale de
célèbres drôles de dames
négation la
compagnie
tout divertir c'est pas strasbourg saint
denis c'est un peu plus raffiné quand
même oui c'est pas pareil
non attends je vais faire une photo
[Applaudissements]
elles sont trop minimes
[Musique]
nous aussi nous avons un rendez vous
galant au plus tôt un rendez vous avec
notre rêve qui auto est la gardienne des
traditions japonaises c'est donc ici que
nous avons choisi d'être initiés à la
cérémonie du thé un rite indispensable
pour notre projet
on
pour atteindre la sérénité nécessaire à
l'exercice rien de mieux qu'une halte
dans l'un des 2000 temple bouddhiste de
la ville
nous voici arrivés dans cette maison
familiale une des rares à enseigner aux
étrangers la cérémonie du thé
notre défi apprendre en quelques heures
une technique millénaire qu'il faut
toute une vie pour maîtriser
attention préparez vos genoux je me
prosterne
et je me prosterne et devant quoi devant
un éventail
quelqu'un rentre respect
ne surtout pas tiqué sur les chaussettes
blanches c'est mal
je crois qu'il s'installe le matériel
et surtout toujours gardé le sourire tu
ne comprends rien tu dis oui à tout ce
qu'on te dit ne jamais contrarier un
japonais même quand tu te propose déçu
et et baguettes
ou bien de découper la nourriture avec
un cure dent
et surtout surtout se sentir à l'aise
j'aimerais d'autrefois m'asseoir
correctement mais j'ai pas assez de
d'habitude oui j'ai passé d'entraînement
donc faudrait s'asseoir comme ça
[Musique]
adam est un truc de façon
générale études presque des mines
[Musique]
mais le truc à ne pas rater c'est de
boire son thé est de bien montrer qu'on
a aimé
doug e mail est fier aussi doivent faire
du bruit à la fin c'est juste les hommes
non enfin louis harel les filles aussi
à mon tour j'ai à peine la pression
gracieux raffiné
une cérémonie du thé peut durer jusqu'à
cinq heures
[Musique]
et voilà comment mon rêve se transforme
en une torture
[Musique]
en tout cas sur les faits
excuse moi pardon pardon
oui non non c'est bon on ne veut pas le
faire souffrir site 6,6 en moins par
respect
des mois là bas
[Rires]
ça fait mal ça fait très très mal moi ce
que j'ai pensé que c'était beaucoup plus
fun que fin je me suis beaucoup plus
amusé que ce que j'imaginais
au dollar à part le fait que je pense
que je vais devoir me faire opérer du
genou bientôt que j'ai cette cérémonie
non je rigole
et surtout je suis très impressionné par
peter qui manifestement été japonais
dans une vie antérieure a déjà fait la
cérémonie si je t'assure kelly était
vraiment très impressionné en choeur
les rapports que tu arrêtes de me voler
la vedette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que ça
et moi tu me laisses comme ça je peux tu
as faim de soufre
[Musique]
enfin j'ai j'assiste à une série milité
pour de vrai et au lieu de regarder sur
mon écran télé ou dans un livre et puis
c'est pas pareil une cérémonie du thé à
kyoto avec un maître lutter et où une
cérémonie du thé dans un bar spécialisé
à paris ça n'a rien à voir ce n'est pas
la même saveur jadot le sens de
discipline et la rigueur
c'était une chose que je comprends
si on veut rester marié montant il faut
qu'on reste comme ça moi je suis avec
mauvais caractère et toi précis pour
certaines choses mais incapable de se
débrouiller sans moi des fois je me sens
que tu ferais s'il m'arrivait quelque
chose
[Musique]
plus que quelques jours avant mon
premier spectacle
pour me relaxer il ya un de mieux que de
prendre la vague à montréal oui oui sur
le fleuve saint laurent
on espère pouvoir comment réussir à
l'est de mossoul pas mal
je pense qu'on va bien s'amuser
à battre et p
étant donné qu'on connaît un peu notre
corps tu vois là sein de l' équilibre va
être peut-être un peu là
moi j'y crois j'y crois
[Musique]
voilà
ok
la cause
[Musique]
m
trop bas
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
ces nouvelles chansons c'est trop
partout j'ai failli partir très loin
ça compte
non
j'ai moins un avant le festival
carmagnole et mes premiers pas devant un
public les artistes sont déjà là pour
les répétitions je viens d'apprendre que
je doit improviser un numéro de
contorsion j'ai la pression comme jamais
alors ce soir on va on va voir
moi je ne sais pas pas plus que toi
c'est comment j'ai taté plaisanciers
j'ai failli me roger rien et du coup
leur meilleur basket ou encore
l'abrogation et là je dis
avoir du mal puisque l'improvisation ça
ne veut pas dire qu énormément
vraiment déjà en premier lieu de cette
sas plaisir fois donc à aucune pression
mais c'est vrai tu vois pas mais je
pense à peu de super chouette pour toi
de pouvoir être sur scène et tout
étriper avec notre
sac au valais et voici ma nouvelle
troupe
[Musique]
est bon metteur en scène patrick léonard
un des fondateurs de la compagnie les 7
doigts de la main quelqu'un qui compte
dans le métier
autour de lui une dizaine d'artistes les
meilleurs du moment c'est parmi eux que
je vais avoir la chance de me produire
[Musique]
et aux commandes du numéro le plus
acrobatiques nos égos
bientôt mon tour pour les répétitions
je fais pas la maline
[Musique]
bellamy
c6 position sans que tu pourrais aller
chercher est bon pour toi
y'a que cette fois la scène
[Musique]
voilà
avec la laisse toi faire
ok regarde moi on ouvre les yeux on
essaie de prendre conscience de l'espace
aussi ok donc la musique commence on
peut se regarder sûr on peut faire un
aspect un peu tango japon d'un petit peu
moins si j'étais tout seul mais aussi la
jeune fille va être avec moi on va être
un perdurer puisque c'est un peu pus
rations qui avait vraiment tout seul en
interne
[Musique]
m
mais même avec hugo à mes côtés je
n'arrive pas à me libérer
le metteur en scène tente de me
décoincer mais rien n'y fait
il alors une super idée faire participer
tous les artistes et faire de moi leur
marionnette
ça va être génial mais mélanie va être
génial je laisse
[Musique]
importunité génial
j'ai pas je peux mais ça les jeux
vraiment faire un jeu vraiment faire de
mon mieux et je suis vraiment impatient
je poursuis mon immersion en nouvelle
calédonie cette fois ci côté terre dans
un décor de western
j'ai rendez vous dans l'exploitation
d'henri un des éleveurs de chevaux les
plus connus sur l'île
avec lui agathe une vétérinaire qui a
fait le choix de s'installer ici
[Musique]
tu parles tu sembles un taux la wii
c'est dur
veuillez nous en fait permet de retarder
sa fierté cicatrisation
donne envie de monter à cheval et
elle est soignée pourquoi pas oui
1 5 le milieu du cheval c'était un peu
pour ça que j'ai voulu faire veto mais
finalement je préfère la gare d'arlon
loisirs ouais donc c'est un monde entend
lever tôt que je ne connais pas du tout
savoir c'est des choses qui sont
vraiment très bien les ducs est très
gentille du coup c'est un bonheur pour
travailler et est donc normal en voilà
et en sécurité il n'y a pas de ça c'est
quand même bien ses chocolats aussi
ouais ouais
[Musique]
avant le lever la tête à plomb
m derrien est pas évident que
ça demandait ça demandait deux en deux
ans pour que le club puisse faire tous
les numéros là je vais faire dans les
rues dont les noms la relation qu henri
partage avec son cheval me touche ça
n'en a pas l'air mais arrivé à coucher
un cheval relève de l'exploit
non mais on ressent vraiment qu'elle a
conscience qu'elle est
en fait celle du mal elle descend en
ligne directe des chevaux des désaccords
donc quand j'étais petit toit les appels
aux as et est le cheval de mes rêves
parce que bassin le cheval des indiens
donc la liberté leur m'ont pas cru les
grands espaces et puis moi j'aime bien
tout ce qui est un peu atypique donc
forcément c'est un cheval qui me
plaisait
voici les biens passage vers en pensez
le cowboy qui dorment à gratter avec son
cheval tout ça mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai
aussi
ben voilà aussi bon pour le travail
henry et son cheval sont comme deux
vieux compagnon de route aujourd'hui en
fin de carrière avec cette malice qu'ils
partagent tous les deux à merveille
[Rires]
c'est vrai que ça fait rêver quoi on
sent qu'il ya une complicité entre les
deux qui est touchante et
qui font envie on envie d'avoir la même
chose
quand même tu vas pas la bière
sally basterds
[Musique]
agathe m'emmène dans son jardin secret
une des plus grandes propriétés
agricoles situées dans le grand ouest
calédonien 1200 hectares au total une
superficie inimaginable en métropole
c'est que l'élevage extensif c'est à
dire que les animaux ne sont pas rentrés
soir à les tables donc du coup pour
savoir s'ils vont bien on va cheval
pratique voilà à défaut en quad mais moi
je préfère le cheval je comprends tu
regardes sont juste derrière les
collines on devrait pas tarder à leur
tomber dessus donc voilà
donc en fait on va les contourner et tu
vas voir il va suffire qu'on parle pour
qu'ils avancent d'accord
je comprends de mieux en mieux le choix
de vie d'agathe et je suis de plus en
plus gagné par l'appel de la
nouvelle-calédonie
être vétérinaire ici c'est à voir sa
salle de consultation en plein air ce
que j'aime bien là c'est ouais le côté
far west un forcément le travail du
bétail mais sous les cocotiers quoi
c'est quelque chose que j'ai imaginé pas
vraiment pas du tout pas c'est vrai que
ces conditions d'exercice qui sont
extraordinaires et qui n'ont rien à voir
avec ce qu'on apprend à l'école
je suis presque décidé à m'installer ici
comme vous
c'est le grand jour dans quelques heures
je vais me produire devant mon premier
public
le festival carmagnole bat son plein
c'est toute la faune du cirque et du
spectacle de rue qui s'est donné rendez
vous au beau milieu de ce champ
c'est parti
dernière répétition avec patrick et sa
troupe et c'est toujours pas gagné
le soutenir le mouvement ac revient
public toi tu étais vraiment été
manipulé par par tout le monde on
exploite on était absurde exploiter les
français gardent
à vous de ne plus jamais faire des
contorsions
ouais c'est beau ça avec l'âge j'avais
peur que ce soit pas à l'aise du coup
qu'elles soient bloqués mais du coup ça
très bien aller en fait ce que je vais
conseiller s'est du coup de profiter du
moment de réaliser son rêve finalement
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est parti pour le show depuis les
coulisses je vois les numéros
s'enchaînent et
[Musique]
là je me sens pas stressé quand même
parce que ça approche pour les
je pense que ça va aller
j'ai envie de leur montrer que
je peux être à la hauteur peut-être de
venir ici dans deux ans
je sais pas
sur scène la barre est très haute
on appelle ce cerceau la roue cyr pour
réaliser ce numéro de quelques minutes
c'est plus de cinq ans de travail
[Musique]
ça va toi
hama
[Applaudissements]
c'est au tour d'hugo de mettre le feu
sur scène et moi je passe juste après ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernier conseil avant de monter sur
scène en de quelque chose de très
spécial aujourd'hui la
[Applaudissements]
spéciale qui est descendue mes premiers
applaudissements d'un cerf-volant ou
pour sentir beaucoup de joie parce que
quand on voit la réaction des gens
qu'ils soient soient présentes ils ont
sonné j'ai entendu les gens un peu puis
ou faire des bruits d'argent à sa place
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas quoi dire sur cette aventure
mais il n'y a pas de mots pour la
décrire tellement c'était
tellement c'était magnifique puisqu'on
se souviendrait toute ma vie parce que
c'était vraiment vraiment support
qui l a été et bravo
tu es content ouais ouais je suis
vraiment content de cette semaine
j'espère trop de fierté
du spectacle vous pouvez malgré 2 bis
stress de l'improvisation
mais franchement bravo super
après notre rigoureuse initiation à la
cérémonie du thé place à la détente ce
soir notre maître du thé stéphane quand
on nous a donné rendez vous dans un
salon nouvelle génération à café tenu
presque par des robots font du bonheur
santé bonheur
or au bout
j'attends de voir ce que ça donne en
spectacle et je suis
déstabilisant et je me demande à quoi
m'attendre
et joe peter
c'est bien pour les épées de la petite
c'est parti pour le show du grand délire
à la japonaise
[Musique]
gros comme ça
[Applaudissements]
et voici les robots non non il ya
vraiment personne à l'intérieur
[Musique]
mon futur à londres et à paris je ne
suis pas sûr de recruter ici mon
personnel
à jouer comme ça dans mon salon et je ne
pense pas un je répète la place de
j'aurais pas le budget
évidemment quand il s'agit de se frotter
à un robot qui est ce qu'on appelle
c'est bibi
[Applaudissements]
non à moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
allez
et voilà c'est la fin héroïque de notre
aventure
suffisent à nous voir au japon un merci
encore c'est un mot un bon retour neil
finn tour je veux dire plus c'est un
fait du monde à plus et je souhaite que
votre salon t fonctionne bien quoi merci
au poker et bien foireux de voir quand
vous avez comme ça et c'est que ce soit
paris battu mac ou téléphone hamas
ça fonctionne merci beaucoup a+ ciao
[Musique]
cette expérience m'a
rassuré sur mon projet et à monsieur
permettre une fois rentrés tous a dû
gérer
de faire quelque chose de plus pertinent
je pense c'est quand même envie être
jbeil moi j'ai trouvé mon opinion and
kenobi
[Musique]
donc
je crois que la force est avec nous
en tout cas la fosse du japon allait
avec
g
[Musique]
alors
c'est parti
donc on part passe de dumbéa et on va
essayer aujourd'hui donc de voir des
requins
ce serait génial
ce spot qui est vraiment réputé pour
pour les requins gris à des
rassemblements dont qui bouge en
fonction des marées on va essayer de les
trouver là sur le premier soit on va
aller on va faire une pause entre 30 et
40 m
j'ai hâte
allez tu vas voir que c'est là où
passent nouvelle calédonie
[Musique]
et devinez qui nous accueille le premier
de la classe un tricot rayé
le spectacle est vite au rendez vous
[Musique]
oh
et soudain le coup de théâtre
un banc de requins soyeux vient à notre
rencontre
je suis subjugué
[Musique]
ma vocation de vétérinaires aînés de
l'admiration que j'ai pour les requins
et là c'est plus d'une dizaine de ces
prédateurs tant redoutée qui vient nous
entourer
[Musique]
oh
j'y vois un signe
j'ai trouvé mon eldorado
[Applaudissements]
c
c'était super c'est impressionnant c'est
fascinant comme vous et moi j'ai la
chance à très très beau un requin
fantastique c'est décidé je poserai mes
valises de vétérinaires ici dans ce bout
du monde
nous aimons que
pleurer mais
non mais c'était à moi j'ai une
expérience
magique je peux pas espérer bien que ce
qu'est ce que j'ai fait cette c'est
vainement donc c'est un au revoir c'est
encore là mais je pense qu'on va être
amenés à se revoir 2 je pense aussi
vraiment mais voilà on est encore merci
j'ai à dire j'ai vécu un rêve mais ouais
c'est ça que c'est exactement ça